welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar playing catch-up
a federal policy is lagging behind state
cannabis programs presented by David
Mann gun director of government affairs
Legislative Counsel or America's for
safe access
my name is Xavier guitars and I will be
your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing your
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem in this
presentation SOG is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming David mango I would
now turn the presentation over there
good afternoon or good morning depending
on what time zone you're streaming this
webinar from my name is David mango and
I am the director of government affairs
for Americans for safe access master
safe access is the nation's largest
nonprofit dedicated to representing the
interests of medical cannabis patients
researchers and professionals
we have about 100,000 members across the
United States and chapters in all 50
states and several of the US territories
who are all working to change cannabis
policy on the state and federal level
and so I'm very excited to be part of
this lab roots
virtual conference and welcome your
questions throughout the presentation
so to begin disclosures aside from my
employment with Americans from state
taxes I have no financial relationship
that could reasonably viewed as a
conflict of interest or an appearance of
a conflict of interest
with any of the other presenters or any
of the products being presented at this
this conference so as I go through this
presentation I hope that there's two
things that really you all can focus on
and the first is identifying what areas
states have have chosen to regulate
medical cannabis and cannabis for
non-medical uses as well as recognizing
what policy change must be left up to
the federal government that can't be
determined by the state so with those
two things in mind I'd like to get
started with a national overview
currently there are 47 states that have
some form of law in the books that is
different from the federal Controlled
Substances Act whether this is a
comprehensive medical cannabis program
program that allows cannabidiol or CBD
only or a program that allows the
non-medical use of cannabis there's a
significant national trend on where
states are headed in terms of countering
federal policy on this issue so the way
our organization looks at these programs
and defines a comprehensive program if
states that offer a substantial access
to
Kandice through a variety of delivery
methods through patience being able to
use medicine through a distribution
system or have protections that are
greater than an affirmative defense and
when folks get prosecuted and arrested
by state law officials so right now we
have 33 states that are considered quote
unquote comprehensive with another seven
another 14 states that have have
cannabidiol only programs within those
states there's there's 10 plus the
District of Columbia that allow for the
non-medical use of cannabis so when you
look at this from a patient perspective
we estimate there's approximately
two-and-a-half million medical cannabis
patients currently in the United States
I couldn't asterisk from this number
because some states like California and
Maryland don't require patients to
obtain an ID cards to receive the
protections of the program some states
do have mandatory requirements that
requires patients to obtain an ID card
participate in a medical cannabis
registry but but some do not so this is
our best guess estimate based on the
numbers that are produced from the
Department of Health and from these
medical cannabis programs within the
state we've estimated that approximately
0.16
- up to 2% of a total population will be
eligible for medical cannabis programs
depending on state condition lists and
how states identify participation in the
program
so obviously even at 2% in states like
Colorado in California this is not
really a sufficient amount of patients
enrolling in a population compared to
the larger healthcare system so the way
we you know I think something that we
typically hear a lot as an advocacy
organization from opponents of the
legalization of medical cannabis is that
everyone will be using this and this
will cause all sorts of problems we
really see that the the use of medical
cannabis is really
strictly limited to an already small
page of population
so the fears and concerns that this
would be widespread and sort of replace
all healthcare systems is sort of a
little bit unfounded so for a graphic
representation of where we are in terms
of panthous loss
this map shows in the darker shaded pink
the safe at half past a comprehensive
medical cannabis program it's primarily
the northeast the west coast I've been a
few states scattered throughout the
middle of the country the stripes pink
indicate states that it passed
cannabidiol only programs these programs
are typically quite limited some of them
do not have in state distribution
systems some are limited only to entrap
what intractable epilepsy but but by and
large these programs don't provide
access for a large list of conditions or
large subsets of the patient population
so looking at this map there's only
three states but don't have any sort of
law on the books whatsoever regarding
medical cannabis or regarding CBD and
those are Idaho South Dakota and
Nebraska and there's already been
interest in Idaho for the 2020 election
with a dalit initiative to to move
forward at mental medical cannabis
legislation there's been interest in the
Nebraska State House about pushing
forward medical cannabis legislation
interestingly enough though the South
Dakota Attorney General recently issued
a memo saying that CBD and hemp are both
still illegal under state law which is
somewhat contradictory to the the farm
bill that was passed earlier this year
that that largely legalized industrial
hemp and CBD derived from plants
containing 0.3 percent or less THC so
we'll be watching these states closely
the three without programs as well as
the states that currently only have CBD
programs to see how they will advance
medical care
this legislation moving forward it's
throughout the rest of 2013 and into
2014 so currently the Controlled
Substances Act and a variety of other
legislative statutes and executive
agencies prevent most of what's
considered legal activity in these state
programs states can go ahead and
legalize programs however they see fit
as we have we've seen since 1996 states
have been you know going against the
federal authority of the Controlled
Substances Act of the Department of
Justice and passing their own cannabis
laws but well states do this
there is no functioning framework under
federal law and under the Constitution
that allows this to actually move
forward there's an argument that the
Tenth Amendment allows states to set
their own policies based on the health
and welfare of their citizens but the
Department of Justice and the Drug
Enforcement Administration has disagreed
with this position and seeing as they
are the prosecuting agencies they would
probably be given deference in in a
federal court at least at this time
we've seen some federal courts agree
with patience and side with states who
have passed these programs but the
official position of our government
agencies on the federal level is that
cannabis of any kind is so illegal
and these laws that are being passed
that allow for the medical use for the
non-medical East's are inconsistent with
federal policy and federal priorities so
[Music]
2014 there was a document issued by the
Department of Justice that seemed to
give some cover for state legal cannabis
businesses this document was known as
the Kohl memorandum it was written and
authored by Deputy Attorney General
James Cole and what this document did is
it outlined eight policies for the
Department of Justice in terms of which
cases they would take to prosecute and
wish they would not
in terms of department resources so this
memo looked at things like restricting
access to minors preventing diversion
preventing grows on public lands and
what this memo did is well it didn't
really create any new law at the
Department of Justice it did outline a
policy that allowed States to develop
programs that were consistent and
compliant with this memo so after 2014
you saw an explosion of states
developing medical cannabis programs
with policy priorities consistent with
this memo some states even took the
memos language and put it into their own
legislative statutes a good example of
this is Alaska where in the statute
itself it lists out the Cole memo
priorities and says the same priorities
exist for Alaska's medical program now
Alaska also allows the non-medical use
of cannabis but the policy priority is
established by the Cole memo are still
very much an integral part of Alaska's
program and so this guidance was I think
something that allowed the industry both
for the medical side and for the
non-medical side to flourish for for the
years following 2014 acted as a cover
and acted as sort of tentative legal
backing that businesses could rely on
when they entered into this space so in
2018 this memorandum and other guidance
that had been issued by the Justice
Department outlining policies when it
came to cannabis were rescinded by then
Attorney General Jeff Sessions for a
while it seemed as though this was going
to be a significant step backwards for
medical cannabis and the medical
cannabis industry however a lot of
players and manufacturers ended up
coalescing around this precision and
making sure that they were very
compliant with with state law and
particularly those state laws that had
identified the same priorities as the
Cole memo
so where we stand right now with this is
Attorney General Sessions issued
guidance returned full prosecutorial
discretion to district attorneys and
federal law enforcement that said that
they could use all resources available
to them to to cross a few cases that
dealt with health cannabis we haven't
really seen that in terms of a federal
crackdown and now Attorney General
William bar in his confirmation hearing
indicated that he would not be using
Justice Department resources to go after
these state programs so aside from this
memo
the only real legal protections that
exist for state level medical cannabis
programs is an amendment that appears
annually in the congressional
appropriations process this amendment
was introduced several times before
finally being incorporated in a spending
bill by representative Sam Farr and
Maurice Hinchey it finally was put into
into place by Sam Farr and Dana
Rohrabacher
and has gone through a few iterations
and his most recent lead and led by a
bloomin power from Oregon and Dave Joyce
from Ohio so what this amendment does is
it prevents the Department of Justice
from spending any money to prosecute
people who are compliant with state law
in terms of implementing medical
cannabis programs and this amendment for
the first time last year was put in
based acts of an appropriations bill
what that means is it did not have to be
voted on on the House floor to be
included as part of the budget so this
certainly marks I think a tepid
acceptance by by some members of
Congress at least that these state
medical cannabis programs particularly
are not doing away and that the federal
government is is taking at least for now
a hands-off approach however there's
amendment you mean the years so there
there's no lasting protections outside
of this appropriations process for these
state programs as they continue to
develop and create their own medical
cannabis laws this protection has been
slightly extended by some Court
decisions the most notable of course is
US versus McIntosh this was a Ninth
Circuit decision that held the
Department of Justice and not spend its
funds to prosecute individuals who are
compliance with state medical cannabis
laws this included patients as well as
healthcare professionals the language of
the appropriations amendment read
directly seems to only cover those for
help helping implement state-level
medical cannabis laws however this seems
to extend these protections to a broader
base of the population so with that all
being said the protections from the
annual appropriations rider as well as
the the decisions that have come from
circuit cases and the the comments and
actions by former and current Attorney
General's leaves us where we currently
are so states in response to I think
California and Maine and Hawaii and
Washington state sort of leading the
early charge to develop medical cannabis
laws have created their policies around
the idea that the federal government
will not be interfering into these state
operations so where states have really
developed this policy as it is in
several categories and the first is
testing and quality control each year
Americans were saved access my
organization grains each state's program
on on where they are in terms of
providing patient access to providing
safe and quality medicine so this map to
the right indicates our grades from last
calendar year and in ending December
31st of 2018 2017 excuse me
and this sort of shows that no program
has achieved an A grade by our standards
yet there are some states that are
closed with D pluses but there's there's
a lot of things even for the states that
have the longest develop programs
they're startled room for improvement so
states having not received guidance from
the federal government I have looked at
several categories where they can
improve access to say medicine and the
first and maybe one is testing and
quality control the federal government
hasn't introduced any standards
whatsoever when it comes to testing
cannabis like they have with some other
agricultural crops pesticide levels so
states have created systems on their own
that create various mechanisms
mechanisms to determine the content of
THC in certain plants the content of
other cannabinoids recall protocols so
these have all been developed without
federal guidance which you typically see
in other other industries and other
agencies they certainly have federal
principles but not in the same way that
we've seen with other regulated
industries pharmaceuticals alcohol etc
states have also had the opportunity to
develop chronic safety controls what
this means is the priorities of the Cole
memo that encouraged preventing
diversions of minors and preventing
diversion generally you've seen many
states implement a track and trace
system where a plant will be monitored
and intensely washed from its scene to a
final sale and then sometimes beyond
you've seen States develop strong
content for packaging for labeling
making sure that things aren't marketed
in a way that they would have killed to
children that they appropriately
identify the active ingredient typically
THC though it could be another two
avenues
and you I think has seen States
approaches in a variety in space
California has done a good job with prop
six before the legislation that passed
their adult use ballot initiative it
called for a lot more testing and
labeling standards however in some
states these are almost non-existent and
you just have to trust the product that
you are getting is what whatever the
dispensary says it is so it's something
that certainly could be improved across
the board if there were minimum federal
standards I like there are there's some
other food products some other
medication products perhaps would help
these states that lag behind in
packaging and labeling and testing
standards develop standards of their own
that effectively and adequately convey
the product that's being sold states
have also been on their own to develop
distribution frameworks under the
Controlled Substances Act federally the
distribution of cannabis can the
associated with jail time with hefty
fines so states have had to figure out
ways and mechanisms to get cannabis to
individual patients some states have
allowed the home cultivation of cannabis
other states to prevent home cultivation
but allow for patients to go to state
licensed dispensaries or allow for only
distribution to just certain people some
allow for delivery so this has been that
sort again a very state-based
approach in terms of how to develop
getting medicines from one point to
another that's outside of the
traditional medical supply chain that
that we see with other medications
states have also been allowed and widely
able to set their own tax rates where
you see a big differences in the states
that has allows for cannabis for
non-medical purposes you typically seen
much higher tax rates then than medical
cannabis some states have decided to tie
their medical cannabis tax rates to the
same rate that pharmaceuticals are tax
in that state some some states have not
wanted to tax patients and not taxes as
a medication but have found other ways
to generate revenues through excise tax
and sales tax but all of the states that
have carried this programs currently has
vastly different approaches to you know
how this is taxed and how this could be
a revenue generator at all then the last
way really that states have developed
policy without guidance from the federal
government is on the issue of civil
rights and this category broadly
includes things like employment testing
child custody proceedings and even some
things that typically lie in the federal
purview like gun ownership but states
have begun to approach the civil rights
aspect of being a medical cannabis
patient
there's no sweeping guidance other than
saying that certain individuals should
lose some of their rights from the
federal government a good example is
from Housing and Urban Development they
have a policy that requires landlords to
deny admits to tenants who are medical
cannabis patients upon application but
if they discover that there is a patient
who is a tenant and they are already
living in a federally subsidized
property it's up to the landlord's
discretion on whether or not they want
to institute eviction proceedings some
states have taken a vastly different
approach for a little bit more more
detail on how we graded these states
what's the difference between an A and
an F I encourage everyone who's watching
this presentation to go onto our website
and look at our state of states report
it has the detailed categories and the
different approaches that the states
have taken on this issue so with the
last two congresses we've seen more
legislative activity than I think we
ever have before in any other
congressional setting in terms of
introduced legislation and things is to
resolve this federal state conflict some
notable ones right now are bills like
the marijuana Justice Act which focuses
on the equity and raychel and justices
caused by the drug war there's a number
of medical cannabis research bills both
through the Veterans Affairs Department
and through other agencies there's a few
that tries to regulate cannabis like
alcohol so there's a lot of interest and
a lot of approaches right now to attempt
to fix this but we still have not done I
think significant enough movement from
the federal government to indicate that
prohibition is ending any time in the
very near future and a reason for this
is some roadblocks to reform many
opponents of cannabis reform point to
the fact that there's a lack of data and
this is a I think a way to hide behind
the tremendous amount of data that I'm
sure will be presented during this
conference as as well as currently
floating out there what these opponents
typically mean is there's not enough
data that's been funded by the United
States federal government there are
plenty of studies from around the world
as well as from private researchers that
show the medical benefits of cannabis
and even a government agency the
National Academy of Sciences engineering
and medicines has issued a extensive
report in 2017 highlighting a review of
the current research and proposing such
findings that cannabis is effective for
chronic pain as well as some other
findings as well so I think with as we
move forward and as more countries
legalize medical Canada
and look forward research is going to be
harder and harder to hide behind this as
a reason for opposition
another reason is despite 94% of public
support for medical cannabis a lot of
lawmakers don't view this as a critical
mass issue there was a poll that was
issued a perspective voters for 2020
it was open-ended and asked what is your
top priority for the 2020 election and
only 2% of respondents indicated
cannabis or drug reform in any way as a
reason why they would go to the polls so
many lawmakers don't see this as a win
or lose issue yet I think that some of
their constituents would disagree and
would be willing to have this be the
sole reason as to why or why not to
elect someone but it's still interesting
than the less though as we move forward
I think there is a concerted effort
particularly in the House of
Representatives to move cannabis policy
forward last year to research bills
passed out of committee
for the first time that was the first
time that we had seen any progress on
cannabis legislation really since the
Controlled Substances Act was passed and
today the day I'm recording this webinar
the House Financial Services Committee
will vote on the same Banking Act which
provides avenues for cannabis businesses
to gain financial services the vote will
have been completed by the time the
labyrinth conference happens later this
week and so the results from that should
be but with a Democratic controlled
house it looks like is going to be a
favorable result alley through the house
side but time will tell the see if the
Senate will also agree with those
persons well there's movement in the
House of Representatives there's not a
whole lot of movement right now with
federal agencies that have a hand in
regulating cannabis all of these logos
right here
our agencies that are in some way tied
to cannabis policy the big ones of
course are organizations like the Drug
Enforcement Administration which
controls illegal boroughs and books to
licensed producers the FDA which is
going to be I think producing more
Kinect kamon of cannabis based medicines
on after the approval of dialects and
then some less obvious ones I included
the logo of the EPA here because Lidia
is issued a notice basically saying that
all cannabis is a non-conforming use so
the EPA won't provide pesticide guidance
for cannabis as a crop I also included
the Department of Education there is
certainly still the risks that
individuals who are granted federal
student loans can lose those loans based
on cannabis traditions and there is a
certainly a fear from research
universities that they don't want to
research the effects of medical cannabis
because they fear that they might lose
federal funding so this goes into a
little bit more detail about the last
slide when we look to some of these
legislative proposals that are currently
floating around Congress a lot of them
deal with rescheduling or D scheduling
cannabis as a substance but doesn't
really talk about what happens so this
slide details changes that certainly
would be needs needed to be taken by
some of these federal agencies to ensure
that the the D scheduling or
rescheduling of cannabis was actually
effective an example is ensuring banking
access or with the Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms ensuring that
medical cannabis patients would be able
to purchase a firearm because there's
currently a federal prohibition on that
so just a touch more on the
Elsie's of federal agencies these
highlights some of the current
restrictions that medical cannabis
patients face of top is a warning from
ATF as they just mentioned the warning
is on a form that's used for sale of
firearms it says warning the possession
or use of marijuana remains unlawful
under federal law regardless of whether
it has been legalized or decriminalized
for for medical or recreational purposes
in the state where she resides ability
and then policies that HUD has put in
place as I mentioned earlier so
recognizing that a lot of federal
agencies need to to do contrary action
to help fix the state federal conflict
my organization Americans first eighth
abscess has proposed a new federal
strategy that consolidates a lot of
federal resources from all of those
agencies and creates a new oversight
body of medical cannabis well this would
allow states to still have some level of
control with licensing but because so
many agencies are involved the National
Institute of drug abuse Drug Enforcement
Administration Department of Justice
the FDA Health and Human Services
it becomes a issue that's the old
expression too many folks and you have
over a dozen agencies trying to
implement influence cannabis policy
right now it just becomes untenable so
we we have proposed to consolidate some
of those efforts and energies we'll see
if that's something that is palpable to
to this Congress but I want to talk a
little bit more about things that the
States cannot do you right now and the
first big one is veteran's health care
states are unable salesmen VA programs
being Veterans Administration are unable
to have those VA care providers assist
our vacations fill out paperwork or
recommendation forms for these state
programs all of those decisions have to
be on the federal level so states can
provide discounts for veterans they can
provide less stringent requirements for
veterans to join their programs but they
can't direct the VA hospitals in those
states to work with veterans and you
effectively pass policy that favors them
states can also not resolve the issue of
dr. protections completely states can
say that it's not a risk to a
professional license if a doctor is
going to recommend a cannabis or
participate in the cannabis program
however doctors can still not prescribe
cannabis because it remains a Schedule
one substance doctors under federal law
are not allowed to prescribe schedule 1
substances so you won't see cannabis on
a prescription pad
well the schedule 1 status remains there
are there is a reason though where
doctors are protected under state law
and that comes from a Supreme Court
decision that says that the
recommendation of medical cannabis is a
First Amendment right rather than
anything that relates to a DEA
registration so that's how states have
developed these programs with doctor
participation the forms that you see
patients spilling out and healthcare
prevent professionals filling out are
called recommendation forms rather than
prescription forms but again the ability
for doctors to prescribe is is something
that would only be able to be changed by
the federal level and this is just an
example of some of these recommendation
forms some are very detailed some nearly
list a list of conditions and require
the doctor to check which condition is
appropriate but again there will be no
prescription
and ultimately no insurance coverage
until the federal government changes the
status of campus so with that that is my
presentation I welcome questions the
landscape in terms of state policy and
federal policy is changing rapidly and
at times it seems like it's almost daily
so I'm happy to answer any questions
either now or or as they come up in the
coming weeks and months thank you so
much thank you David for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible and
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again say goodbye